when you're um on saturday night live
and you start dating someone famous
is there like this pressure too to keep
it quiet because you don't want to be a
cliche like you don't want oh yeah you
know
an onset romance people start to see you
they don't even see you anymore they
just see you with scarlett johansson's
boyfriend
you know that could happen you know what
i mean yeah
yeah i know i that was that was
definitely
a worry um the lucky thing was that
people in the cast
really liked her when she was there as a
host
it wasn't like i was dating someone who
was like a monster and then
was around and that kind of thing but
yeah i i i worried about my identity
with it
and and and and also it's comedy you
know you work in comedy so
i i was always always worried about
anything that felt non-comedy you know
or
or took me out of a world of comedy and
i remember even like
shay and i went to the mark twain awards
with chappelle when he got
when he won the mark twain award and i
remember it was the same weekend as
there was
some event in la that scarlett had for
press for like you know the lead up to
all her stuff for the oscars and all
that
i remember lauren and che were like come
with us to the mark twain thing like
do that and i was like oh yeah all right
i was and it was i wanted of course to
do that but it was nice to have your
boss to command you to do it
and you're like yeah it's good you want
you have to keep your own you know you
have to keep your own identity and do
your own
thing the only thing i couldn't deal
with is uh the love scenes
it really is difficult to see the person
you love kissing someone else even if it
is an acting situation
yeah i you know it hasn't i don't
think it's really happened uh that i've
experienced it yet since we've been
dating
a driver with uh with that fantastic
performance uh
american story marijuana story yeah
fantastic but do they i get
do they but it's do they kiss and then
maybe i don't think maybe they don't but
but i do you know even the idea of her
like hanging out with adam driver that
long on a set
[ __ ] happens on these sets as you know i
i just don't like it it's hard
it really is hard i i know i'm gonna get
i'm gonna try to push her into a lot
more animated stuff
just just all voice work
i think probably you know five ten years
ago it would have
been each of these things you're
describing would have been devastating
if people want to be together and and
love each other they're gonna be
together
and that's you have to kind of like have
faith in that on some level and and
and if not then you're not going to be i
was thinking for you with covid19 just
say look no more love scenes i don't
care i'm not a jealous guy but i don't
want to
a medical level yeah that's a good
that's a great loophole